tragic situation in Hollywood uh TV line
reports the sag-aftra strike is already
putting a squeeze on actors finances
even for an Emmy winner Billy Porter who
shot the fame and won an Emmy on the FX
drama pose now says he has to sell his
house due to the financial strain of the
strike
I have to sell my house he tells the
UK's evening standard because we're on
strike
I don't know if that quote was really
necessary just literally restates
exactly what we said in the sentence
before so this is bad writing but it
doesn't matter
um for an artist like Porter
uh quote until you make Fu money which I
haven't made yet life is still paycheck
to paycheck he says I was supposed to be
in a new movie and on a new television
show starting in September none of that
is happening
this is a tragic story Billy Porter uh I
mean this this is the face of the
tragedy unfolding in Hollywood right now
okay while you continue on with your
lives
um totally ignoring
this horrific tragedy that is happening
right now in Hollywood
and you have men like uh uh excuse me
thems like Billy Porter whatever he
identifies as
uh
who who are we're supposed to be in a
movie in September and now they can and
now the movie's been delayed
terrible terrible stuff
Porter also took a shot at the anonymous
Hollywood executive who told deadline
that the goal was to drag out the strike
until writers and actors were forced to
sell their homes
quote so to the person who said we're
going to starve them out until they have
to sell their Apartments well you've
already starved me out
I know this is the best he's not putting
himself in the best negotiating position
here
um
and uh he goes on and says
to hear Bob Iger CEO of Disney say that
our demands for a living wage are
unrealistic while he makes 78 000 a day
I don't have any words for it but Fu
that's not useful so I have to keep my
mouth shut I haven't engaged because I'm
so enraged
yes Billy Porter just wants a living
wage so now we're being told that that
Billy that a Emmy winning actor
is not making a living wage according to
according to them is that dark spot on
your face still bothering you what about
the liver spots on your hands neck and
chest that I can see all over you
hideous monster well now you can watch
them disappear safely and quickly in
three quick minutes introducing the
genucel Dark Spot Corrector their
three-step a three minute dark spot
luxury system does exactly what it
sounds like by using their crystals
microdermabrasion before the Dark Spot
Corrector and finishing with a touch of
the collagen building genucel 15 you'll
see the dark spots disappear before your
very eyes instantly smoothly and
luxuriously but don't take my word for
it if you're not blown away with the
results you get 100 of your money back
no questions asked free shipping and
free returns all three products are
included in general cell's most popular
package for August so you get your
genocell bags and puffiness serum also
included for 70 off retail go to
genucel.com Walsh YT order the new dark
spot treatment system today and say
goodbye to those pesky spots tomorrow
that's genucel.com
Walsh YT for those who don't recall
here's what Billy Porter looks like I
think we have the let's put that picture
up
so that's just what he looks like uh
this guy's not making a living wage he
tells us
so maybe if you spent less money you
know dressing up like the evil queen
from Narnia uh maybe you'd have enough
money to pay for his home maybe you
could pay his mortgage if he wasn't
spending it on whatever the hell that is
just a thought
but there are a lot of stories like this
these Tales of Woe
uh that are coming out of Hollywood and
the problem for these Hollywood actors
and writers
as the as the strike
lingers on and you know going on for
many months now
and in many of these reports they're
kind of complaining that there's not
like nobody cares like no one's paying
attention to them
and the reason for this was two reasons
first of all so you this is this is all
self-inflicted you've chosen to uh
you've chosen to go on strike
you don't have to but you did
uh well really three reasons second
reason is the obvious one the many of
these people that are on the picket line
are like millionaires so it's a little
bit hard to feel sorry for them and then
and then third
it
you're asking for sympathy from people
who have never received any from you
um
because when have any of these people
shown any concern for our well-being
I saw someone you know bring up this
point on Twitter I don't remember who
but
it would be very interesting to go back
and I'm sure we could
and I don't know if Billy Porter I'm
going to assume that Billy Porter is
probably part of this
be very interesting to go back
and find these actors that are
complaining because they want more money
or whatever and they're asking for
everyone's sympathy and find what they
were saying during the covid lockdowns
and how many of them were in uh doing
PSAs when they were telling us all to
well just stay home give up your job
doesn't matter if you're not making
money we're all in this together
remember we're all in this together
and they said that while they continued
working the entire time
and now they come to us begging for
sympathy and uh there's just not much
that we can provide unfortunately for
them hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there